what was uh what was your take away from
the bitcoin conference and any uh
insights or things you walked away
surprised by
uh
yeah there wasn't really any huge
announcements i didn't feel like not
like uh
not like last year last year there's a
lot of kind of big announcements but i
just think the biggest takeaway for me
was the amount of people there it was
incredible to have
25 30 000 people there coming for a
bitcoin conference coming to talk about
bitcoin
uh the the fact that it just keeps
growing every year i think is a really
good sign where we're going um
no surprises really um i thought well
jack announced it's pretty cool i think
that's one of those things that doesn't
feel like a big announcement but when
you really look into it's quite a big
deal i'd like to understand more about
um more about that so i'll talk to him
at some point i also think you look at
the guests
you know
uh we had some big guests last year but
now you've got jordan peterson there
eric weinstein's there odell beckham jr
of the says aaron rodgers williams it's
crazy yeah and you know these people i
mean some especially someone like aaron
rodgers you know he isn't just there for
the sake of being there he understands
bitcoin he invests in bitcoin companies
so
uh and it's very based yeah yeah
but it's just it's clearly breaking out
now into an even bigger mainstream and
is that a good thing or a bad thing i
mean
what are we trying to achieve here um
sound money for everyone then it's a
good thing because more people are aware
it's becoming more acceptable i also
think it's um
we're starting to get a real
kind of regulatory protection now
because so many people hold bitcoin
you're seeing that shift with
politicians now whereby actually you
know politicians really they're just
hunting for votes none of them really
stand for much and the game theory works
out that so many people have bitcoin now
that you're starting to see a lot of
politicians come in who are pro bitcoin
i mean you probably have the same as me
everyone wants to try and come on your
show oh i'm pro bitcoin can i come on
your show and what's your policy like do
you want to do politicians or no uh
not for the politician's sake if they
are interesting and they've got
something cool i'll have senator lamazon
because i know she's a bitcoiner yeah
and knows so you you try to put some
sort of test on like do they actually
understand it or they just
kind of uh grandstanding case case by
case yeah i would have ted cruz on
because i think he's he's kind of put
himself out there and yeah um and case
by case as well yeah it's case by case
most of the others we've done one and we
do a second one it's exactly the same
interview and actually when you dig in
most of them don't really understand
bitcoin i think eric adams is a great
example in new york of how you can get
rug pulled on bitcoin i mean he came out
as a pro bitcoin guy and then starts
once he gets in power he starts joining
[ __ ] so is eric adams the biggest
disappointment uh in the intersection of
politics and uh bitcoin so far
absolutely i mean he rugbled everyone um
i think he's a disgrace
yeah and i think he's i don't i can't
see any change in new york since he's
come in i mean what do you mean that he
rug pulled everyone well he said he was
pro bitcoin he had i think he even had
bitcoin in his profile
salary
paychecks in bitcoin and then he just
starts to attack bitcoin mining straight
away and so i just think he's a
disappointment he didn't understand
bitcoin um he's full of [ __ ] so yeah
he's a disappointment but i think
there'll be plenty more like this but i
think that will work against them as
well you know if you're going to use
bitcoin as a way to get votes and you're
going to rock paul the bitcoiners that's
not going to end well for you do you
think we'll get to a point where being
pro bitcoin is a requirement for
these politicians running for office i
mean are we i think red states already
is i think you're already there in red
states uh what would be interesting to
see what happens in the blue states uh i
know you had row conor and right yeah
yeah i think
one of the most important things for me
right now in bitcoin is that uh
that bitcoin doesn't become some kind of
partisan issue and that's really
important now and you can certainly see
it go in that direction now
you know elizabeth warren is not
particularly helping the cause of the
moment with her
fad that she's spreading about bitcoin
so i
i think it's very easy to engage with
republicans who are pro bitcoin i think
actually what's more important now is
where you actually talk to democrat
politicians and trying to convince them
and convert them so actually that's a
good that's a good point uh pomp if a
democrat wanted to come on i'm more
likely to take them than a republican
now because i i really want to i really
want to see if they
do understand this and we're about to go
through the same in the uk
uh you know we've had a very the europe
itself has been very anti let's say
crypto broadly i know you cover [ __ ]
coins here um
but we'll get into it
eur europe has been very very anti
crypto not pro crypto at all and i think
the the uk has finally realized now with
now that we're out of the eu this is an
opportunity for the uk and richie soon
actually said you know we need to
understand and accept uh crypto we want
to be the center of the world for crypto
i think they're a bit late for that um
and they're behind el salvador already
uh let alone but is this like is that
the thing that they should try to do
right like if i was a politician do i
want to be the center or should i
actually just optimize for let's get in
the game right exactly
to me it's like that like when you say
we want to be the capital of uh the
bitcoin industry
that feels maybe there's two to three
places in the world right now that have
a shot at that i would say texas has a
shot at that right i would say el
salvador has a shot at that and maybe we
could debate you know two or three other
cities right miami
maybe but it feels like without the
mining uh or without kind of going all
in it's hard to do um but the uk could
be the center of europe
exactly like that's a more obtainable
goal
than we somehow are going to convince
everyone to give up where they are and
move to europe i mean look where all the
the bitcoin companies are the majority
are in the us you've got a few scattered
around you've got like ledger in france
et cetera and you know um hoddle huddle
i can't remember exactly where they are
in europe but the majorities here in the
u.s and a lot of the big exchanges and
some out in asia and then some on some
weird
tax beneficial islands
um
but i think what the uk needs to do is
just be pro
bitcoin even pro crypto i think it's
hard to be pro crypto
pro bitcoin and anti-crypto but i just
think they need to create an environment
where people can buy trade
and build businesses with
cryptocurrencies and that's what they
need to do to begin with so
i i think we're we're starting to see
that matt hancock uh has been pro
uh crypto and there's like three or four
others who have been on richie soon
actually said here so we've got to see
whether they are real about this or
whether it's just going to be another
rug pool but hopefully uh
the hopefully uk will hey you did you
like this video great we make five of
them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time